[Music]
and stressful job news submitted by
Rolex Smart Watch what Oh face book
content reviewers are not coping well
with the stress of repeatedly viewing
graphic and offensive material that's a
good job for serial killers yeah or like
people that are like crazy but like they
have these urges to look at crazy things
but they might also say oh the
decapitation that's not graphic yeah and
it's kind of like yeah Dobby taught like
a criteria though because yeah
objective-c it and then they won't be
emotionally affected by it but then they
know oh man like Dexter like Dexter's
told good from bad he knows but he still
got these arches right right you know
they lack empathy and they have to learn
yeah what that is right people just need
longer vacation times to unwind and
better breaks some of the things you
can't unsee though so we got a cop buddy
and he sees like maybe three to four
crazy [ __ ] every single day there's a
cop buddy that I met yeah okay well that
makes one of the pictures he showed me
was of they got a call to a suicide so
it was like a 40 year old lady that got
into a big fight with her boyfriend some
[ __ ] happens and then she she'd grabbed
the gun and she put it in her mouth and
she pulled the trigger so the picture
that the picture that he showed me this
chick was in a bathrobe still on the
floor and brains and puddle oh [ __ ] and
I'm like that's [ __ ] free yeah yeah
and he's like I see [ __ ] like that three
to four times a night and in person and
you got a deal with the smell before
times are nice yeah that there's this
crazy [ __ ] all the time like that's
going down I saw that that terrorist
video that came out on like Facebook and
everything you mean the beheadings the
beheading that was pretty I saw that I
saw that one I just heard the guy scream
in his voice sort of gurgling
blood that [ __ ] traumatized me for like
a couple months yeah you know on
Facebook I couldn't watch anything I
feel like I I feel like I want like just
by watching Holly like you know like
horror movies and just movies in general
has desensitized me to the real [ __ ] cuz
if I do see this stuff now it's kind of
weird like it's it's not
I should be more affected by it I do you
think you might be if it was in person
like live like you saw that should
happen in front of you
maybe yeah but I mean it's still will
but I feel like just if I didn't watch
those movies in the first place I think
it would be affecting even more like I'd
be like oh my god [ __ ] christ yeah I
think there's no way you can't be
desensitized with like all the graphic
content that's out there but also even
within that I think some people are
still just a little bit more squeamish
they can't handle no yeah certain things
like blah no no I like blood I don't
like vomit but I don't know I'd like
I've seen the beheading video and I
didn't get squeamish from him I saw it I
was a serial killer I saw and I'm like
that's [ __ ] up and I and I and I feel
terrible for that meeting
oh yeah that's true I get squeamish when
I watch someone get kicked in the nuts
but that beheading video didn't [ __ ] me
up the way that I actually miss be good
like you know those fail videos where
guys would skateboard and I'll hit your
nuts right right I'm like oh [ __ ] but
that's something violent leaving me
because you have an experience thing you
know what the ball hitting feels like
maybe it's not even that it's just like
when you when I watch that video I could
hear the how scared that person was and
I think a crime for their lives and I
could hear how angry the other person
was so that emotion felt too visceral
for me it just felt too real you even
just describing it it's make me feel so
because as he's about to get beheaded
the guy is like scream and then it
wasn't even that it was more the guys
whatever he was chanting before he was
gonna do it he was saying in rage almost
as if he was convincing himself that he
has to do this it almost sounded like he
didn't want to do it and he had to do it
anyways for the whatever cause that he
was doing and that [ __ ] made me feel
really uncomfortable yeah you know did
you see the
cartel decapitating one I didn't see
that's crazy
shit's crazy because they do it like
this is the thousandth time they've done
it yeah it's just the silence yes it is
just so it was just like go grab the
other lady in the guy business as usual
you're just like all over the world
we're just talking about it and it's
kind of like oh that's sad imagine
watching this [ __ ] yeah great day yeah
that's the cafeteria videos I get passed
by my Facebook feed to this [ __ ]
Daily Mail kept putting it up there and
I'm like what the [ __ ] so I'm like I
don't even want to find out what my
reaction what they need to do look at it
you know how when you're like shopping
for cologne they gave you a coffee being
a smell hmm so in between every graphic
thing they just got to look at Keroppi
or some [ __ ] because over here what
we're talking about here is gonna see
something cute some [ __ ] Hello Kitty
people getting killed so like when's
their brain okay so - we're talking
about here so Facebook's content
moderation facility in Arizona it's
operated by a vendor called cognizant
and so these employees here these
moderators they are paid $15 an hour so
like nowhere near what these actual
faces it's a manual process then like
somebody's sitting there someone's
sitting there and actually reviewing
every single thing that you flagged and
so they're saying that that's good to
know
yeah like the verge did this whole like
a report on these people and so they
spoke to a lot of these employees
current and ex employees and for example
one of them said that he carries a gun
with him where he goes because he's
scared of people that have gotten fired
or if someone finds out who the content
review people are and then they get a
they get upset because they're offensive
material was taken down or something and
then they come and try to retaliate oh
you couldn't even find out who's
reviewing these that's no um they do
teach that they'll develop their own
PTSD yeah yeah exactly they actually
have developed PTSD and other employees
they
sex with each other in like the bathroom
and stuff just to like release the
stress yeah that's a good excuse why
it's like I'm so stressed I have to do
it I have to bust a nut I'm sorry did
you see the decapitation video awesome
just in order to help with the intense
people don't [ __ ] at the workplace yeah
they [ __ ] Afghanistan the military
people they [ __ ] it up yeah they [ __ ]
everywhere yeah for sure and then
they're also using drive I'm sure
there's some sex I there's like some
psychological [ __ ] where they need to
like connect in a different way I'd like
to feel like human again you know I mean
oh yeah yes true yeah I'm like if I'm
like nervous I'm like hurry somebody
suck my dick like Costco workers by [ __ ]
each other but I think at this level so
I feel for these guys cuz I I feel for
them too
there's just the funny excuse yeah I
just don't really see it as an excuse
but um I feel for them as I'm sure
everyone else in this room does too I
hate watching news because I know it's
all for ratings I know it's all drama
based I know it's just to [ __ ] with you
but my mom really likes watching the
news so when I'm at home I respect to
her I just let her watch whatever she's
watching and and it's like there's the
news at like 1 2 3 4 and they just keep
repeating the same [ __ ] Moonie stories
I don't picture mom going yeah I mean
they just the whole time so I'm there
and I'm listen to these stories and like
you to affects me to the point where
like I'm trying not to even think about
it or hear it or let it affect me but it
does even the way they announce [ __ ]
makes me nervous yeah and like and I'm
like oh [ __ ] I feel like I should carry
a gun these days now because like all
the [ __ ] that they're reporting but then
I have to like pull myself away from
that I'd be like nah dude like this is
if I watch the news - would you want to
[ __ ] me - I think if I'm watching very
dramatic and like very traumatizing
things like that I think I would need
anything to feel some sort of different
people have different ways of coping -
sex is just one form another for
drugs we're going to work by its bug
most of the time nobody drama from that
studying what you're like I can't like I
could understand how it's [ __ ] them
up like mentally because you know yeah
you look at it from like a doctor right
like doctors can't look at their
patients as human beings they can even
look at them as objects to basically
separate is once they start thinking
about them as human beings they can't do
what they need to do that's why they
talk so much [ __ ] during the surgery no
but but that connects to their marital
relationships when they lot of doctors
law enforcement they have problems at
home because they have a hard time like
getting back to human interaction like
okay I can't be if you like OBGYN I
can't be aroused by female parts so give
me that [ __ ] give me that armpit
whatever but they go home and then they
try to be intimate with their partner
but they can't because it's true it's
like turned on and off they know like a
switch so we're seeing special if you
see it every day
1990s [ __ ] and you won't we see the
bad side of [ __ ] too if your OBGYN you
get the stank and you get the rose be
for you get everything oh man but
Blissey always looks good though not if
they got extra roast beef though no but
the Buzzi way it cleans it all up and
you got the butt cheek stuff yeah it all
matter here they're saying that yeah
they're saying that um they don't they
provide a therapist or someone to talk
to during work time but then like the
standards that they they make these
employees have they have to have like a
95% accuracy rate which is like
and then they had to meet like they're
certain they don't have a technical
quota but they're like oh if you have to
review 200 posts or whatever like in and
then you end up asking for help for one
particular post because there's a guy
walking around that gets paid $1 an hour
more
um and then he's supposed to be like
super knowledgeable of all the Facebook
policies and stuff and then he'll come
over and but then that takes time away
from the rest of your quota you need a
fulfill and then I guess just the the
pressure is crazy and then what you're
actually consuming by reviewing
everything is intense you know the thing
is to like these people are just normal
ass people it's not like you're being
trained to be desensitized to this thing
you pick it up on the job where it's
like a doctor or a cop they have to go
through a certain amount of time and
training before they can practice what
it is they're practicing this is just
okay sit in the computer in front of a
computer and flag all these you know
graphic content that's true what if
you're like a [ __ ] Gulf farmer and
now he's looking at people town of like
a hundred people everyone's nice they
nobody locks their doors and [ __ ] and
you're like there's a new job fifteen
dollars an hour and they [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] they're like the world is crazy man
that'll be shocking dude that'll be so
sure you know what don't you guys feel
effects of that too though like ever
since technology became so integrated
with their life don't you just kind of
feel more desensitize the bad news and
like the bad things that are happening
because you're bombarded with it all the
time before you caught it in like
moments now it's like 24/7 if you're on
the phone looking at news outlets
there's I don't even need that we have
tip for JK news my whole mind all the
time
[Music]
[Music]